we do though have some very sad breaking
news
to bring you now and captain tom moore
has died at the age of a hundred
a statement from his daughters hannah
and lucy said it is with great sadness
that we announce the death of our dear
father
captain sir tom moore we are so grateful
that we were with captain tom during the
last
hours of his life hannah benji and
georgia by his bedside
and lucy on facetime
captain satom moore he was 100 and had
captured
the nation's hearts with his fundraising
efforts during the coronavirus pandemic
has died
after being tested after testing
positive for coronavirus
iva bennett looks back on his life and
legacy
when the nation needed a hero it found
captain tom mall
his quiet determination to complete a
sponsored walk
a source of hope when it seemed there
was none
the army veteran aimed to complete a
hundred laps of his garden before his
100th birthday
to raise money for the nhs his target
was a thousand pounds
he eventually raised more than 32
million who would ever
thought that something like this would
happen
from a little family probably joke for
200 000 pounds it got into this
enormous and it really is an enormous
sun
with the country on a war footing this
military man from yorkshire
made people believe the enemy virus
could be defeated in recognition
an raf flypass marked his centenary by
which time he'd become a national
treasure
more than a hundred thousand people sent
him a birthday card
among his well-wishers the queen and the
prime minister
i know i speak for the whole country
when i say
we wish you a very happy 100th birthday
and in what was the queen's first
official in-person engagement
after the pandemic began captain tom
became captain
certo the ceremony specially adapted for
the open air
to allow one icon to meet another face
to face
cementing his celebrity status a number
one single with michael ball
making him the oldest person to top the
charts
[Applause]
[Music]
really demonstrated that you're never
too old to
make a massive difference you'll never
do anything
um to uh to to do something new
but also i think it was the hope that he
bought and the optimism
that he bought to everybody um
particularly during that first
lockdown when things were so new
and unsure for absolutely everybody
captain saton was admitted to bedford
hospital with coronavirus at the end of
january
when he required help with his breathing
he'd been receiving treatment for
pneumonia before that which meant he
hadn't been vaccinated against covid19
the disease he had done so much to help
the nhs battle
ultimately claimed his life but having
inspired so many
his legacy will live on please
do do remember that things will get
better
even in the darkest of times captain tom
saw light the sun will shine and will
never walk alone and just do this
i believe that to be true a message we'd
all do well
to remember iva bennett sky news